My name is Tang Guangyu, founder and CEO of BabyBus
Everyone calls me "Donald Duck”
and I’m hoping this amusing nickname brings more happiness to all the children
As a father
I used to watch my kids playing and having fun
so that I have to keep finding new ways for them to play
Our team has many young parents and education experts
together we are trying to determine the most suitable and enjoyable
educational app for each and every kid across different age groups
We hope that our “bus” get the same magical power
to travel around the world and to deliver surprises and happiness to every child
like Santa Claus
Now, BabyBus's “Magic” just got a lot stronger
with Google Play’s firm supports
My name is Louis
Co-founder and App Manager of BabyBus
Currently, 80% of our international users are using Android
Starting from September 2015
all of our apps joined the “Designed for Families” section
so that kids and parents can easily find the app
based on their interest
Our downloads has increased by 367% comparing with last year
“Ice Cream & Smoothies” is our most popular app on Google Play
it was officially promoted on Google Play homepage
During that week, it gained more than 1.36 million downloads
and our other apps received more than 6.12 million downloads altogether
My name is Ling Ying, Product Manager of BabyBus
We pay a lot of attention to our overseas users
we have created 12 different languages versions for most of our apps
which allows them to meet local user's preferences
Thanks to Google Play App Translation Service
our users are able to read content in their native language
Admob is the main method we use for app monetization
it provides more than 90% of total income from oversea markets
Cooperating with Google Play
is the key to our success in oversea markets
We released our first app on Google Play in 2012
now we have 103 apps in the market at the same time
with the number of total downloads exceeding 150 million
With Google Play’s support
we believe we will continue to bring great educational products for children around the world